my name is vishal singh
i am a product lead for data products at
starburst
today we'll be talking about how you can
easily create and curate
data from different sources and convert
them into data products
uh before i actually go talk about data
products i also want to use
this time
to talk about one of the really recent
product which we have released uh which
is galaxy so i'm going to do a quick
demo into starburst galaxy then talk
around how easy it is to
create create data products using
servers so
signing on up for galaxy is really
straightforward so what is galaxy galaxy
is a sas platform
where
you can
connect your data sets across different
sources
and it's completely uh service server
less but still you have you can create
clusters and you can
you know you can actually connect data
set to the clusters and uh write queries
to your data sets no matter where it
exists so here i'm going to hit start
frame
ask for some basic information
i'm going to add my
email address create an account
it sends me a code to my email uh i will
look for a code on my email give me a
second
should be the internet is little
finicky here why am i getting the code
um i do have an account up and running
for the galaxy
which is here once you sign up in the
galaxy
why galaxy is really powerful to connect
your data sources
if you look at the number of catalogs i
have built
in the galaxy is
azure mysql azure postgres
also google
on my sql i also have a catalog from aws
so galaxy from get go is multi-cloud and
you can connect to the data sources not
in single cloud but you can connect your
data sets across all different cloud
once the data set are configured
you go create clusters
and clusters are also being created into
the cloud
where you're connecting a data set
so you may want to create a cluster in
aws
to query the data into aws
and you can actually create a cluster in
gcp and azure and maintain all the
multi-cloud clusters in single place
so you don't have to go to the aws azure
or gcp to actually get insights in your
data sets you're getting insights into
right into single platform which is
service galaxy
once all my clusters are set up you can
see this gcp cluster which is suspended
at the moment
uh awesome cluster which is running an
azure cluster which is also suspended
one thing we have done in galaxy
is that you pay for how much clusters
you're running and when the queries are
running when but when the queries are
not running the clusters goes
automatically in the suspended mode so
you're not paying
if no queries are being written against
a data set or data source
so as i expand this cluster azure east i
can go back to the cluster screen and
you can see it's automatically started
and this doesn't have to be in the
galaxy itself
the moment you write a query into your
tableau power bi or any dashboard it
automatically will detect the cluster
will automatically be detect a query has
been written and it's been executed and
cluster will come into starting mode
as you can see cluster is now in running
mode so within few seconds
the cluster is already running into
azure and i can write queries against it
so let's go back to the query history
query editor
and i can load azure east i can look at
a different data source
into azure
i can also look in data into aws
but not just that i can even write
queries against lake house
run the query here
and get the results right there
or if i want to join
data between rds
and s3 i can do that too right here
and run the data between rds server and
s3
so that is in our roadmap to run the
queries between uh cloud we cannot do
that in the galaxy but the the part of
my demo on the data products we can run
the query across cloud
and that i'll be showing that too which
is on the enterprise solution does allow
you to run queries across different
cloud
this one
so this is the name of the the the data
set or the schema which has been created
so it's just the so what the way the
syntax work is that you can see the
postgres is the name of the uh data
source which contain different table the
one of the
different schemas and one of the schema
is public and the customer is a table
under that schema
so you're joining those data source data
sets or tables as if they are different
tables
even though they are different data
sources
now
let's move
as i talked about galaxy and let's see
if i got my code
to
yes i got my code i said internet little
slow here so 2
9 0
7 9 4.
i can create an account let's call this
data console
and that's it now you're in galaxy
you can uh i'm going to use some
suggestions create a password
and you're in galaxy you can play with
the sample data set there's a free tier
in galaxy which allows you should never
have to pay it's a demo cluster you can
play with it understand and learn galaxy
without even
paying starburst a single penny you can
just play with the demo clusters
and
you also get
a 180 free credits
to experiment with our bigger clusters
with extra large and large clusters
where you can write bigger queries to
understand how galaxy will be performant
in your organization
and that's all it takes for the galaxy
for up and running and you can connect
your data into data lake and write
queries against it
but the main topic of this workshop was
not galaxy i just want to take an
opportunity to talk about galaxy the
main
topic of this workshop is data products
before i talk data products
i want to
talk around
the three different personas and their
roles in the organization
and how they work with the data and how
they're using trino a starbucks trainer
to share the data within
the organization within domain itself
i'm looking at aaron aaron the admin
who's the katie
is a data analyst in the marketing
department
and john
is
external vendor coming from ousted in to
work with katie in her organization
they are all logged in through the same
cluster
and they have the same endpoint but
their views are very different
if you look at the aaron's view
aaron is looking through all his data
sets
and all his data sources
no matter where it exists
and i'm going to stress on it no matter
where it exists
aaron is looking through data into aws
cosmodb delta which is on azure
snowflake
mysql kafka iceberg
and has views into all his data sources
all his data set across every cloud and
on-prem in a single view
so adam does not have to go figure out
where is the data into s3 on azure or
sorry
on aws where is the object storage data
into
azure or where's the data for my google
you can build this view right here for
aaron
even
and can join
data across snowflake and
hive on demand
so there are some data sets exist in
snowflake some on the lake and i want to
join those sets
how do i do that aaron is in unique
position using starburst trino
and as i run this query
i got the results here
and this data sets
are coming from two different places
warehouse and lake
let's look at the katie's view
has no access to snowflake katie has no
idea where data exists katie does not
even care where data exists
katie is data analyst
she works in marketing department and
she cares about getting access to the
data she works day by day
katie has access to two different
product finance product and marketing
product which she works on
in the her current
role
katie had reached out to aaron to get
information around otters
because that is one of the data sets
missing from the finance products she's
working on
aaron knows that those data set exists
in snowflake and lake
and i will either move the data into a
warehouse or move the data to a lake
in order to give katy access to that
data set
but using starbustrino and does not have
to do that
and can share the data
as the one of the semantic view this
could be either view or a materialized
view
from the query which i just ran
and if i go back look into the kds view
i have access to order information
katie can write query against other
information
and start working with her data sets
within few seconds of asking aaron can i
get the accessor data set
and it does not have to move the data
and does not have to copy the data just
created the view across
two different sources and this could be
two different cloud
this could be on-prem and cloud one of
our customers are combining the data
between on-prem and cloud to gain
insight to give insight to our to their
data consumers
where they can get insight into legacy
data and the data which exists in cloud
itself
but let's look at the john's view
if i look at the john's view in the john
does not have access to finance product
john just have access to marketing
product
john may also need access to auto
information
katie is not an admin he's not a data
admin
katie is data consumer how can she
actually give access to john
to a data set because she does not have
control over data governance tool or the
access control
katie does know
that john has access to marketing
product
so kd can share
the data the order information data into
the marketing information data too
run this query
and results came out to be true
here
i have order information here
john was also able to get the access to
our information
one thing happened for john you'll see
the phone number is mass for john
well
it was not for katie
so even though katie was able to share
the data with john
there's some pii information data was
not shared
because using starburst you can define
the policies
into
external vendors what they will and can
see before even the data is created
so as katie was able to share the data
john got access data
within the governance policies created
by the governor's team
and the data said
respected those policies
now we are taking this concept this is
trino
so trino
already has this we are taking this
concept
and creating
a more packaged way of sharing
create creating and curating data set so
that it can be easily shared
and discovered within the context of a
domain
or
are the the department one is working on
so let's go to the cades view
click on data products
kd
can look into all the data products
across all the organization
or even the filtered data products
by
one of the many organizations she is
working on i can look data products in
sales i can look at data product sales
and marketing
thus katie has been a task to work on
the customer segmentation information of
of the data
how will katie find the data set
as i type
it goes through the all the metadata
and the column information
and search goes to finding the data set
which our data product which katie is
looking for
i click here
and i can see
that this data set contains customer
segmentation and product type
information have more description and
has two data set part of it
it belongs to
engineering domain and there are two
data product owners matt and vishal and
some tags on it and also some links
which could be
internal documentation
where one can go read and look into what
this data products serve
i can expand customer segmentation
information
and hit preview
all the metadata which you see on the
data products page is searchable
so more metadata is input the better it
is for data consumer
kd or anyone to come in and find the
data product or data set they are
looking for
i expanded this you can see the credit
card number is masked for the kd
i can look at all the information
let's go back to the john's view
look at the same data product customer
segmentation and information
and hit preview
credit card number is still mass for
john
because john is still vendor
but you may also notice the estimated
income is no
so john cannot see the estimated income
while kd can
so even the same data product has a two
different views
based on two different users and two
different domains they are working on
katie can see all the customer segments
which is gold platinum silver
but if i look at the john's view john
just see the silver customer segment
because john's task is to just work on
the silver segment of the customers
it's the same data but the different
views for the different use cases and
different
users
in a different department
this data set
could either be
a view which i just showed or
it could be a materialized view
where you can see when was the data
refreshed
and when was the next refresh coming in
that why materialize view because your
data could be on google bigquery on
snowflake
and on s3
but you are running a cluster on s3 then
you can materialize your data set close
to the cluster
and it have incremental update but that
allows you that even though customers
are hitting the data set across three
cloud they are hitting the local cache
which provides better network latency
and the customer does not have to pay
for data transfer cost for every query
which is executed against that data set
now let's go back
and take the query which we just used
and create that into the data product
ahead
let's call this order information
i can choose
one of the many catalogs
to publish this beta product
at the moment these are hive catalog in
the future we'll have support for delta
and iceberg 2. so you can create data
products within those catalogs
you'll see the schema name was
automatically generated why was schema
name automatically generate and no
choice for it the reason behind
generating the schema name
is
enable data consumers to use the data
products in the downstream tools
what i mean by downstream tools if i
look in tableau
when katie looks on the tableau
katie looks at all the data products
and has the one-to-one mapping into what
katie saw
in starburst here the customer
information segmentation information
product credit card default product so
the schema name is generated
by the name you give it to data product
which is useful for data consumers to
understand which data product they're
consuming
in the tool of your choice which could
be tableau power bi liquor hotspot or
any other tools
i'm going to assign this to marketing
domain
i don't know where this should exist but
i'm going to actually for now
assign this to marketing domain hit some
summary summary is what you see on the
page when you land on the tile
so
and description could be a long
description for
data consumers or anybody to come and
understand what this purpose this data
product serve
now i'm going to add the data set
here let's call this also order
information
description you can add even description
on the data set too
more metadata as i keep saying
will be helpful for the discovery
of the data set and the data product
because all these texts are searchable
i can choose
it to be either a view
or a materialized view in materialized
view you have an option how often that
you want data to be refreshed
or you can create a view which data will
always be recent based on where it is
coming from
head
show columns and add description
the column name and data type was
automatically populated based on the
data sources and the query you have
written
and you can add column description
for understand what these columns mean
because sometimes the column description
sometimes the column name could be very
cryptic
it could be one two three x y z but you
can have a better column description
and i can preview the data it's here
i can add another data set if i want to
it's going to go through the same flow
or i can save this as a draft if i do
not know what else i need to do
so this because creating data product is
not a one-time process it requires
understanding what needs to be done
so you can save the data product as a
draft come back re-edit it keep working
on it and publish it when you're ready
to publish that data product
let's add some product owners
i'm going to add a team next to it
you can add as many
product owner possible for the sheer
reason because they are not one product
owner a manager managing a data product
and multiple so you can have multiple
product manager or owners for that data
product
and define some tags
i can i add let's say sales tags can
also add a new tag which does not exist
here
or use one of the existing tags
add links these links
are useful
for data consumer to not only see
what the data product description and
summary has but to read the processes
around how this was created
how you can get even access to this data
product
and who owns it what is the lifecycle
around it it could be internal
documentation and you can attach those
documentation right here
you can say url
and this
now the data product is ready to be
published there is one data set here
and i have published this data product
but once i publish this data product
our users may not know what is the first
few set of useful queries i should be
writing against this data product
and this is why we have also added the
usage examples
where you can have some basic queries
which would be useful for data consumers
to understand what this data product
returned
in order to show that let me go back to
the customer segmentation here
and i have seen some use examples here
high value customers having diamond
status and estimated income of 200k
you can add as many excuses examples in
the data product
this will allow your data consumers to
come in and get up and running a lot
faster than trying to figure out what
kind of quality should i even be writing
against this data
product can preview right from here as
you know katie does not have access to
credit card number so it's still math
for her
and
but we didn't stop
just creating a data product
what else was one adam wants to do
adam would also like to understand
how
can i how what kind of uses people are
writing queries
and how the data product is being used
in my organization
and can take advantage of our query
history
and take a look
into all the queries which has been
executed against
a data product customer segmentation
from
january 1st of this year
i can even look at the trend
of how queries were executed
and you may notice that the this data
product was not popular in the february
but the popularity has decreasing
because number of queries being executed
on this data product is going down in
the month of
march you can also see which are the
users who are writing cpu extensive
queries against this data product
and which are the users who are just
writing most number of queries
you can gather so data product is not
just about sharing the data but also
understanding the the metrics and uses
and the trend of the data set in your
organization and and can get that data
right using our query history
information in starburst
and can also look into which are the
different
tools
being used
to
to be being used
to write queries against this data
product you can say inside is the query
editor
the jdbc because i've been using tableau
which could be re named as tableau but i
it's like right now it comes between
your jdbc driver or data product most of
the queries are being run against using
preview
or whatnot in the data product this is
why the data products is number one
where the queries are being executed for
that data product
but let's go into the kds view one more
time
here as you saw
that they i can look into the data
product i can create the data product
but katie can even federate a cross data
product
so now
not only your fed rating across
different sources or from cloud from
data sources but katie can hear look
into all the different data products
and write queries against that
katie
has also asked to aaron can i have the
you know aaron has published the other
information as a part of a new data
product but can you actually have other
information as a part of the customer
segmentation because that's where it
belongs
aaron
and one thing i'd like to show as you
can see that the customer segmentation
has two tables you can look at both
tables here but let's add
one more
data set into
customer segmentation information
we can edit it
yes so these are like you see this data
set which i was showing a customer
segmentation has two different uh data
set into it but one of the first query
which has is actually fed rated across
hive my sql and postgres but for data
consumer
they don't care
they are looking at data product and
you're looking at data set like this is
my order information
totally
totally yep
in in fact
here this is the same query as
materialized view which i have added
and
let's add
let's add one more data set
which is order information which i just
created a new
data product for it
i'm going to skip the column description
for now
save continue
and as you added the new data set it
just comes in what changes you have made
and now you can publish those changes
but
why
i'm showing this process because if i go
back
and look into tableau
let me refresh it
you'll see other information in tableau
itself too
so once somebody has subscribed to your
data product and using a data product in
to one of the downstream tools like
tableau or power bi
a change into data set or data product
will not just be reflected in starburst
but will be reflected in all the
downstream tools is being used
by
so here
used to be only just two
tables but now the third table order
information just popped up
now katie
can actually
have the order information as a part of
the customer segmentation
and has some data from the
nations
and these are two different data
products she can visualize in our
query editor
and even
write a query
a second
me
let me actually walk by behind this and
and write a completely
new query i have no idea
why this is doing
this
yeah this is i have no idea why saying
commuter it just like doesn't even
i'll i'll let this one go uh
this is
that is the weirdest thing ever i have
no idea why even saying immune is not
even anywhere in the mirror itself so uh
let me actually delete this and then
create
[Laughter]
um
yeah let's uh
so but the the point is that you can use
two different data products and combine
to come up with a completely new insight
and you can then create data product out
of that query
so now what you're doing you're taking a
data product from marketing department
and you're taking data products from the
sales department
and combining and coming up the whole
new data product which can be consumed
again
so instead of sharing the raw data set
or data sets into snowflake or hive or
whatnot you are now sharing the business
context around the business inside and
people are combining and federating
across those insights
to create a completely new insight that
can be consumed
but how does this all fit in with the
domain concept which i completely
skipped for a second
let's look into
our domains
here
aaron can create multiple domains such
as crm engineering marketing
other domains
and
can also assign
admin for those domain
so if i look into katie's view
kd does have access to all the domain
and can see all the data products into
those domain
but if i switch a role for kd
to be sales and edge domain and katie
just have access to only those domain i
think katie does not see data products
coming out of the other domain
katie only see the
data products
also domains which she has been assigned
to
i can look into data product in sales
domain
i can even edit it
or i can look in the data probably
marketing domain
and you see katie cannot edit it
so katie is
the admin for
sales and the eng domain but katie is
the consumer of data products coming
from the marketing domain
and this all can be done
really seamlessly within starburst you
can even give access to just one data
product to an external vendor so when
they log in they don't even see all the
data products across all the domain just
just see the data product which they
have access to
or in the case of john
john can look for a sales data product
which just says q4 product
and
will want to hit preview
but john get access denied
looking at the data for the sales
product
why because
there are issues in the organization
when people do not know if the data
exists
using data product you can give access
to metadata itself
but not give access to data itself
when so john can come in and look for
that data does exist in my organization
but i cannot access it
in that case john can reach out to data
product owner for asking for access to
that data product
in future we'll also be adding a request
access button right here where john can
actually hit request access and the
workflow of giving access
exists within starburst itself
any questions
so no so we use their compute so the way
it works is that we you run with
snowflake and and if you have one to
access against snowflake and let's call
it delta
and so we use go to the snowflake
compute fetch the data
which the query has asked so what we do
is like we have a coordinator and we
have different workers a coordinator is
smart enough to break the query down
and push down the queries which has been
asked for the snowflake data and only
those data comes out of snowflake
and then we take a data out of delta and
combine those data within the our
trinity cluster and the results get out
to the user who has asked for who have
run the quarry
and and snowflake yes
so you it will not be but you can create
materialized views where instead of if
somebody is running the same data set
from snowflake again and again then you
can cache the data into object storage
and starburst or in your location
and then even though there will be uh
people may see that they are writing
queries against snowflake but those are
actually coming against the cast which
just you have created using starburst
so these policies can be i so you have
really good questions so i have used
ranger to define those policies so we
work with ranger immuta privacera all
the governance tool but we also have our
own native access policies so just in
case if you do not want to use ranger if
you do not want to use a muta and if you
want to use the policies right you can
use the privileges and assign the
policies right in starburst 2.
in fact in my demo i'm using both our
native access control and rangers so you
can not only just use one policy control
you can use multiple policy control
using starburst
yep
totally yes yep
so there are two ways one is the
starburst needs to have access to your
table between snowflake and delta so
whatever star buses access that
starburst get to see but then you can
instead of for example if you want to
define and manage your policies in
databricks or into snowflake or into
delta or whatnot then you will have to
go manage into 10 different places
because of starburst you can manage you
can bring all the data here in starburst
and then manage the policies based on
tables and not the warehouse itself or
the lake itself you can say like this
user have access to this table in the
warehouse this table into lake and
you're managing a single point of access
single point of access and growing in
the service itself
yeah
exactly
yeah because otherwise you'll end up if
you have let's say elasticsearch then
you're maintaining it there if you have
sql then you're maintaining it there so
instead of managing
policies into 10 different places it's
easier to manage the policy in one place
because if you remove something you know
that you're removing the person
from all the different sources not just
one source
yep
um tom do you know
this is why i'm glad time is in the call
i mean that question would have been
but uh so as i'm talking to let's
actually walk through i had some slides
but i'm going to skip all the slides i'm
going to go directly into
what you saw and what we'll be building
is coming
everything you saw
on the
on the data product
is also can be done by our using api
which is going to be coming soon our
whole data product is a json blur
so you may create a data product using
your csd pipeline where you actually
keep the json blurb into let's say
github and you may manage and change the
metadata there and as it has been
changed you push those using apis within
starburst so you don't have to create
data products using our ui i mean even
though we are going to be adding more
and more ui functionality but those
functionality will also exist using our
apis too
then one of the key things we are
thinking about is the versioning of data
product itself
because what you what someone may do is
a drop a column change a column type
um
you know remove a table in that case
one should be easily able to do
have breaking changes in their product
and data set but you would not want your
data consumer waking up in the morning
and all the dashboards are broken
because they know there's a breaking
change was introduced in the data
product so we'll keep versions of the
all the data set in the data product and
we have metrics information where you
can see how many people are still using
the older version and how many folks
have migrated to the newer version and
based on that they can you retire the
older version or have a time retirement
on when the older version should stop
working
so starburst uh so starburst
goods
so the one which i started the demo with
the galaxy uh is the completely sas
which works you know in our plane but
the demo which i'm going giving you data
products is the uh uh uh you install it
yourself
so it's basically you have a web url and
everything but you install it on your
side on your infrastructure
in aws or azure gcp but yes in aws too
yep
totally yes so we don't store data even
now in our sas it's just a compute is
there but data is will always be owned
by you
so uh the our sas is like we own the
compute because you can actually manage
the compute across multiple cloud in one
single place and but you can connect to
the data across your lake either in gcp
or azure or aws
so the cash so the cash service when i
was talking about in the uh service
enterprise it runs on your environment
so it's just like you can actually cash
it and uh you're getting cash on your
account
yeah i mean they so
yeah
i mean the you see even the caching
there's so the two parts to the question
uh caching in galaxy is not there yet so
when it comes out uh we'll figure out
like where you're gonna store it on our
side or on your side but again we are
targeting your lake so we can still cash
on your leg but this is something we are
still trying to figure out where the
road map will go uh so i don't have a
exact answer on the sas side but the
enterprise side everything is on your
side
totally
totally yes
yes
so at the moment you have to add the
description again
but we have got that request from our
customers that they should follow up so
there is
yes
totally we do have integration with dbd
uh but again uh as the data products
that what we showed you is our v1
version into creating the whole uh the
data product from the data source to the
the curated version and in future we'll
be working on more better uh dvd
integration and airflow integration of
creating the data products
totally
totally yeah uh so i mean i uh there has
to be again there has to be some
integration with dvd and data products
uh what the integration will look like
it's hard to say right now
but i totally see and again you're not
the first person asking for it but i
totally see the integration coming in
the future
well i was saying like yeah the couple
of things we're working on like audit
trail like we want to know uh what p
folks have done and audited
um we're going to be adding common
section into the data products when
people can come in not just rate the
data product but the commented
um
lineage
because we you can you want to know
which data products was created from
this data product and what raw data sets
are used
so we'll have the
visual lineage of that data set and data
products in the data product tab too
yes
so
so um
there's no
i mean that's an organizational thing
but let's see there's no direct solution
that's why we are adding comments and
stuff we are also going to be adding
like one of the functionality like you
like jira has where you can say like tag
that this data product relates to other
data product so if let's say somebody
found it because it becomes the open
ended community and somebody's like this
data product another data product is
almost the same then people can relate
and you know link those data products
saying these are almost the same or
they're duplicates of it so that's well
that's one way to approach it but it's
really sometime the
as i said democratization and open-end
system could be good and bad because
and that's why we are adding the
certification flow where you can certify
and approve the data products which
folks will see so even though you may
allow like everyone can create it but
you can also have a domain where you can
say only certified data products will go
in that domain and when people come into
that domain they get to see nothing but
the certified data product
and in the data product itself
for let me go back here
and if i want to for example
move this order information
data product in just different domain i
can easily assign this after it's
certified to sales domain and now the
data product is in sales domain so we
will be adding where the data products
goes into different domain are certified
for what role or for what use so you can
create processes using domain
when one could be like a complete
playground one could be just for the
production
it's it's it's a long-term goal we want
to have uh but and not at the moment uh
but yes we will probably have some kind
of relationship which is the question
uh uh was asked like yeah yeah yeah like
really you know that uh it's duplicate
or related or whatnot i mean the quick
one to do is the
uh the lineage so if there are data
products related to
let's say the same data source you can
click it then you can see
totally i mean you're spot on that's the
direction we definitely want to go but
again it was just like one step at a
time but totally spot on because they're
especially when
in the bigger organization they're
different silos and then you probably
search the data product but you may not
know that
some people who are using this their
writing data query against this data
product they may also be writing queries
against the the same the different data
from a different domain
the the point the way you should query
history we are recording all the
data in our system so we have all the
queries we know how the queries are
written it's a matter of time reaching
to the point and creating that feature
i mean one thing we are going to be
adding is that tags not just on the data
product but the tags on the data set
level 2 and the columns so you can
actually
even have like these columns or pii
columns these columns are other columns
and you know so
things like that
which is on our roadmap to to be added
but
it's it's there are some organizational
stuff when it comes to data mesh and uh
i think
what we have from more from all the
customers we have chatted and talked
more open system is better than more
close
especially as data is growing because
one of our customers literally have
bought the same data set into two
different business units bought the
exactly same data set because they
didn't know that existed
so they end up paying for the same data
set twice
and we want to eliminate that because
you don't have to keep buying and
because the as the organization becomes
complex and big they are doing the same
work again and again
so
again there there are some uh you know
the data sheets on your table and also
the uh
how you can uh
find a
a
sign for the galaxy so there's a qr code
on your desktop i'll play with galaxy
too uh there's a lot of new stuff coming
in galaxy 2 there's a
timeline for data products to actually
also go in the galaxy where you can
actually creating the data products not
just
yet no
sure
yeah
and then that will
i mean for us it's just like we don't as
i said like we
every the one of the challenges we have
seen is like
people have used cases why they want to
use warehouse or snowflake or a lake or
iceberg or whatnot i mean every
technology has this use case and why
this exists
and all we are trying to do is like let
our customers have an optionality of
what they want to use for the what tasks
they're running and we're just creating
the insight for all your data sets data
sources in single place
no answers
tommy you're being recorded
[Laughter]
no no i'm just joking
no but yeah it's our
we this is what like we compliment your
technology we don't compete with them
and then that's that's our motive from
day one
like you you choose what's right for you
and then there's we have never also
found
where someone was successfully able to
use
just one thing and move everything in
one thing
and even like even like lake two you
move to lake uh have an european region
you have in u.s region you have like now
we have distributed lake and how do you
combine the data across that so it's
it's hard to actually just move the data
into just single region single place so
and that's where starburst comes in
i hope it was useful one
thank you thanks everyone
[Applause]